welcome to all of you thank you very
much to the international chapters for
the opportunity to talk with you today
about immersive reality for health on
the screen in front of you you see our
beautiful National Library of Medicine
buildings at the National Institutes of
Health we've been part of the National
Institutes of Health for over 50 years
um but we are this is the first time a
nurse has led the National Library of
Medicine you can well imagine that some
of my colleagues who are pretty nervous
when they saw this nurse coming in what
you heard in the presentation of the
various chapter activities brings
forward the power of Nursing and why it
matters to have a nurse thinker as the
head of the National Library of Medicine
now I'm also a nurse researcher and I do
research using virtual reality so I'll
be describing a little bit about my
research program some of the challenges
we've experienced in that and also talk
to you a little bit about the National
Library of Medicine
as was indicated earlier I have no
personal disclosures and the opinions
that I'm presenting are my own not part
of the United States government and I
work towards reducing any types of
stereotypical thinking in my
presentation about patients nurses or
our health care care provider colleagues
watch this video with me to see the
future that I think we're moving towards
um
with you
thank you
please know that the National Library of
Medicine is a partner in the use of
Advanced Technologies and advanced
information tools for health importantly
we'll be talking today about it virtual
reality Advanced visualization but it's
getting harder and harder to separate
Advanced visualization from artificial
intelligence and in the advanced
analytics that make these visualizations
possible I'll try to keep it clear so we
can learn from this but I want to begin
by something well familiar to nurses and
that is the the uh this need to begin
from objectives what will we be doing to
address the needs from for the future
through these virtual reality platforms
specifically as nurses and we have to
address some new challenges addressing
new measurement and methodological
changes that make a difference when
you're using a virtual environment as
opposed to a physical environment
let's begin though by thinking about
nursing care the line in front of you
depicts a year in the life of a person
this person may have had a fracture goes
to through surgery the second image has
recovery and then is discharged perhaps
with the medication goes for follow-up
care and continues to be appraised to
the health system this is a very typical
Journey for nursing but what we know
most importantly is the technologies
that have been available to nurses often
address all of those thin little lines
across the trajectory our goal the goal
of my research and frankly the goal of
my whole operation at the nlm is to go
to the care between the care the white
spaces so we can bring information
knowledge and Technologies into the
places where people live work and supply
now they our usual attempts for doing
that is through interpersonal strategies
in nursing our usual research studies
biological physiological and
psychological experiences with patients
today I'm going to be talking to you
about virtual reality but I'd like to
spend a little time with you discussing
what virtual reality is and what it is
not virtual reality is a term that has
been around actually for almost 40 years
it refers to any use of technology to
mimic the sensory and behavioral cues of
the real world some of you may have
experienced Second Life a computer
platform that was popular about 20 years
ago that allowed individuals looking at
a computer screen to pick an avatar a
computer-generated image that that
depicted them and moved through various
environments maybe for learning maybe
some of you even attended a virtual
poster session which was very popular in
nursing at the time the virtual reality
I'm going to be talking to you about
today is the immersive virtual reality
the the use of computer Technologies to
create experiences as if being there in
an environment where the cues are
actually computer generated you see on
the very far left they can a computer
interaction with a nurse and a patient
that's not really what I'm meaning when
I'm talking about virtual reality I'm
talking now about the use of visual
cueing that doesn't really exist in the
world and provides a predictive stimuli
to a patient for example in the
left-hand screen you see a young man
looking at an odd container of orange
juice and the nutrition information
about that orange juice hovers over that
this is a vision of what assistive
augmentation or assistive reality might
might appear in the future to help us
make better choices in the moment in the
middle screen you see a scientist
looking at a clinical excuse me a
biological structure what the scientist
is visualizing is actually seeing that
large head mounted device around the
scientist but what you see depicted on
the screen is what the scientist is
seeing importantly her hand gestures are
moving the scene in front of her so we
have interaction not only visually but
also by gesture
in the lower right hand screen you see a
young man in a city but overlaying the
city are particular
indicators or markers that suggest this
is a building this is a restaurant this
is where you can go to get some clothing
those opportunities to Overlay reality
with virtual reality are becoming
popular as ways to help guide people
through everyday living so you see what
care what what distinguishes virtual
reality immersive virtual reality today
is the use of a special device to
visualize the experience the environment
with seeing things that are not
physically present in the environment
but created by the virtual images
at the advanced visualization laboratory
at the National Institute of nursing
research at the National Institutes of
Health we are focusing on creating
experimental virtual environments to
explore self-management behaviors in
context on the right hand side you see
the members of my team we have a
multi-disciplinary team including nurses
Engineers computer scientists behavioral
scientists our contribution to nursing
knowledge but it arises because we are
we are focusing on understanding Health
in the context of a person's everyday
living and their lives and our virtual
environment allows us to create the
context within which we can help
understand Health behaviors though our
work at the National Institutes of
Nursing Research focuses on accelerating
the use of advanced visualization to be
quite honest I'm just curious about
where immersive VR is going to take
nursing and what we can do with it that
we might not have thought about before
so we partner across the campus to
evaluate ways that can advance our
research right now we're working on a
partnership with a Symphony conductor
envisioning how a virtual Orchestra
might allow a symphony a new a new
conductor the opportunity to practice
but allow our team the opportunity to
understand gesture-based interaction so
we have very interesting Partnerships
our first challenge that we took on is
to imagine how immersive virtual reality
or ivr could understand and it could
help Advance nursing's understanding of
managing Health in everyday living now
in order to understand which health
problems were the most important we
impounded a group of Home Care nurses
and we asked them what kind of
challenges do people experience at home
and what we learned is there are three
key challenges there are many many
challenges but there are three that came
up the most often first was Diet
management how do I pick a diet that
adheres to either the restrictions or
the foods that are most necessary for me
to stay healthy second medication
management how do I know how to take my
medications particularly if I need to
alter the schedules from day to day or
maybe I'll take certain medications only
as needed and third equipment management
how do I handle a respirator or how do I
handle a CPAP machine how do I
self-administer a injection to myself
understanding how to do all of these in
the context of somebody's everyday
living is the challenge we took on think
about households for a minute we need to
understand where is better understanding
of the environment really need to happen
where does it matter envision your
bathroom at home for a minute or your
kitchen where do you keep medications
how do you remember what dietary
guidance you're supposed to follow we
also needed to understand what could we
study in immersive virtual reality and
what could we not study right now
immersive virtual reality is best for
gross motor activities fine motor
activities such as picking out a pill
from a pill bottle and putting it into a
pill store are much harder to manage in
a virtual environment we can talk about
those in the Q a session if you want so
we took on the challenge of managing
diets and we created a virtual grocery
store the ABB mark this is an entire
visualization that you are seeing on the
screen now and we use this immersive
space to walk participants walk research
participants through the process of
picking foods for a week or a day or a
meal in a grocery we're presenting
health information in the moment in the
context that is in the grocery store
where the individual is practicing how
they they establish their and choose
foods for their diet what's important
about this and you'll see in our next
video is we want to give people the
experience that is pretty similar to
actually being in a grocery store
environment now some of you may
immediately say well wait that doesn't
look like the grocery store in my
neighborhood it's less crowded there's
no people in it there's different kinds
of foodstuffs the advantage of virtual
reality is we can tailor to the local
environment where where the our studies
are being conducted take a minute and
watch this video with me I'm gonna
talk you through what we do and I mean
then we'll go into some more depth about
the study so here you see how we assess
responses to questionnaires we give the
individual a an experience problem with
a question
now you can't walk in our VR but you can
teleport so we have a wand that allows
you to press forward leading up to the
area of the store where you'd like to
purchase or like to select an object
that is appropriate for your meal as you
start to select you use the wand to
point to items on the shelf and those
items in turn will appear in a
description window that comes in front
of you as you're seeing coming on the
screen right now the participant is
prompted to say what do you want to do
do you want to buy do you want to
compare this with other things remember
we give people a dietary food challenge
so that these questions allow them to
mimic their actual Behavior how do I
choose a low sodium alternative how do I
put together a nutritious meal with low
calories
this is what our grocery store currently
looks like from above you see across the
top seven or eight aisles of foodstuffs
on the right hand side you see what
would be a typical produce station at
the end you see cashier stations and you
also see sitting areas common in U.S
grocery stores right now we see
um the the uh uh scooters being offered
snap bars being available so you see
there's sitting areas up front I need to
pause from it and say I am not able to
see any of the chats so if there's a
concern about my speaking could someone
come off mute and let me know what it is
please
our grocery store is created in the
unity platform this is a commercial
platform that provides us with a number
of tools so we don't have to construct
every single object it also brings into
our environments the kind of physics you
need to have to make the world
believable so an individual can't walk
through a series of shelves or an object
when it's picked up stays intact in the
beginning of our studies in VR we
actually had some problems in this area
including picking up a bottle of pills
and forgetting that the pills had to
come along with the bottle so a a
virtual bottle of pills would move but
the actual virtual pills stayed on the
Shelf wasn't very helpful
in our environment we want to make the
spaces real as possible so we've added
avatars to the environment some of these
avatars move and some of them do not
move but they make an individual feel as
greater presence feel as if they are in
the environmental space that they expect
we also use avatars we also use objects
rather to create obstructions to make
the space again feel more real we're
going to talk a little bit about how
real do you have to make a virtual
environment to make sure it's actually
really useful to what you want to be
studying
now in creating our immersive virtual
environment and measuring performance we
faced a number of challenges and I'm
going to go through four key challenges
that we're facing the first one is the
requirements definition any of you
who've worked in Information Technology
design know that you begin every
situation by defining the requirements
what problem matters and what do we have
to do to manage that problem our focus
groups helped us with that diet and
medication management we're two they're
two important ones as I indicated
earlier second we had to think about as
nurses what are the challenges in
carrying out instrumental activities of
daily living and we know while there are
many there are two that particularly
challenge our patients all at home the
first one is the recall remembering
clinical advice and applying it to
Everyday living so when a clinician
tells you to have that you should follow
a low sodium diet does that mean you
should take the salt shaker off the
table or does that mean you should start
Consulting the sodium information on the
food labels the challenge of changing
from a recommendation to go to a low
sodium diet to actually figuring out how
to put together meals when food
packaging is not the same size as an
everyday meal really does challenge
charge take the individual in the food
store and places them under kind of a
cognitive strain so we wanted to also
look at cognitive fatigue are people
exhausted by all of this mental
mathematics that they have to do figure
out if there's Force servings in a case
and each serving has 80 milligrams of
sodium how many servings can I have in a
day Etc we also know that cognitive
fatigue can be induced by too much
visual stimulation so think about going
to a noisy crowded grocery store we also
know auditory stimulation and auditory
distractions can make it difficult for
people to carry out these activities so
our environment allows us to mimic both
the mental challenges of planning and
acquiring proper food
for managing your diet as well as the
immersed experience the noise the
distraction the other aspects we created
uh two environments in our our studies
the grocery stores have almost spoke the
speaking of today we also have created a
home environment if you come to visit us
or come to our website you can see more
about that we've been testing
feasibility and performance there are
many challenges to conducting a study in
virtual reality including helping people
get familiar and comfortable with the
virtual environment making sure that the
virtual visual stimulation rather does
not induce what was referred to as
simulator sickness earlier virtual
environments used to make people a
little nauseous because there was a
delay between the movement of the
individual their head movement for
example and the change of the visual
cues in the environment
we have already brought 24 people
through our study and we've learned
we've measured things such as cognitive
fatigue task burden using a standard
measure called the NASA TLX and
Locomotion or moving about the space we
are launching a study in the next
several weeks to look at the ability of
patients to select Foods in accordance
with the sodium-restricted diet and
eventually we'll be used creating a
household environment to help people
Envision measure making their medication
decision making at home
excuse me
um we use a head mounted display to
bring a person into the immersive
environment so there are many approaches
to hurt to immersive virtual reality uh
virtual reality caves is an alternative
we do not use that we use this set of
goggles that you see on the screen here
and in the upper right hand corner you
can see one of our staff members is
helping a person put this on this device
is still rather heavy and it is somewhat
awkward we don't expect that people will
eventually walk around that world with
virtual reality devices on but for now
this this device is allowing us to place
a person in a deeply immersive
environment so we can begin to
understand the micro behaviors and
responses on the lower right hand side
you see the controllers that one uses by
pressing those buttons one locomotes or
moves to the store also pressing other
buttons allows for selecting and
dropping off of objects in our uh in in
the selection process
this is what our laboratory looks like
at the National Institutes of Health
because of the nature of our studies
individuals sit as they experience the
virtual environment moving through it
through a process of teleporting so
they're they're they are safely sitting
still but still able to move through a
fairly large space you'll notice that
there's two what we call Towers or
emitters that are next to the person's
seat those emitters help to provide the
3D orientation making sure that the
image that is displayed is aligned with
the person's visual field so if you look
across the three slides from left to
right you'll see that the person's head
is moving and as their head moves they
see different parts of the virtual
environment
you'll notice that the head mounted
device is in place in a way that no
light enters this so the person is
totally div involved in the environment
and you'll notice that we do always have
a staff member in the room with the
individuals so no one's in there alone
now one of the things that we we have
tried to do is to make sure that we
understand behaviors in order to
understand behaviors we have to give
people a task to do in the environment
we have found that as we give people a
task to do they are much more
comfortable doing it if they see
indicators in the environment that make
the environment look more real we call
those avatars on the right hand side of
the screen you see a human and then you
see the Avatar of that human this is an
example of something that is an extreme
Recreation of a humanoid look as an
avatar and we've actually found that
going too far making our avatars too
real makes people uncomfortable
in the left hand side I want to talk
with you about something that we've has
been known in both the gaming industry
and now in virtual reality and that's
called The Uncanny Valley this the the
graph you see on the side has two axises
one is a is familiarity and the other is
human likeness and as as as
images become more familiar people
become more comfortable with them as
images become closer to a human looking
like a human people become more
comfortable to a point and then if the
image becomes if the Avatar's image
becomes too real it gets uncomfortable
for the individual they call that the
uncanny valley that is the virtual space
looks too familiar and it causes a just
a distress in the individual as they're
in the environment so when we're trying
to use Virtual Reality for nursing
research in these ways we want to make
sure that we create environments that
are acceptable and useful to people and
not frightening
our measurement challenges are not
insignificant as I've noted that people
are not actually walking and when we
want to understand where they are we
need to understand as you see on the
right hand side where an individual is
in three-dimensional space so
understanding their location which way
are they looking and how much are they
moving are our three first challenges
and we're able to study this very
precisely but we have to study it in a
meaningful way we also look at things
like Behavior how much do people explore
an environment attention where do they
pay their attention and what their own
experiences are including did they feel
like they were actually in an
environment
understanding movement has been the
focus of one of our he works in our
first year here and under if you look at
the lower right hand corner you'll see
the trajectory that one of our
participants took through the store that
is they walked up and down aisles
returning to some aisles and and
spending only a short period of time in
other aisles in order to understand
movement we've looked at the Excursion
the amount of distance people have made
we've looked at reversals how much do
people turn around and we've also looked
at St at stationary moments how much do
they stand still and actually look at an
object as you see in the center here
these are very important aspects of of
understanding human behavior in a
virtual environment because they help us
understand the correlates of choice so
if I'm looking for a particular food
object do I wander through the store and
do I get distracted or do I go directly
and search for that particular object
our use of virtual reality is helping us
to understand the micro behaviors of
self-management
in Merced virtual reality support
nursing science well fundamentally We
Believe immersive virtual reality
enhances the relevance the rigor and the
reproducibility of nursing research
because the environment is fixed in
standards we're better able to
understand the clinical and Human
Experience of a person in context but
the environment also allows us to have
very precise measurement perhaps much
more precise than we can have in a
physical world and we can recreate the
exact experimental conditions over and
over again this gives us a uh a much
more stable environment for research now
virtual reality has the capacity to
accelerate bench to bedside translation
and we're excited about these clinical
applications that we see now and in the
future as we look to the future of using
virtual reality we look to see where
images make a difference here are three
that you may come across first is
exposure therapy we found for people
with psychological disorder orders
particularly fears that exposing an
individual to high places or being in
front of an audience in virtual reality
is a safe place safe way to do that
exposure therapy we found that people
can rehearse complex care activities in
a virtual environment and then transfer
that learning to a real environment we
also have are beginning to see
applications of what we call aided
visualization if you see the patient on
the right hand side superimposed on that
patient are the coordinates of regained
through an Imaging study now precisely
placed on the individual which would
help in surgical planning
we envision immersive virtual reality
moving out of the laboratory into the
community as devices get less expensive
and easier for people to use we have a
project going on at the unit at the NIH
right now where cancer patients are sent
to Virtual Reality headset that gives
them a relaxation experience to manage
their anxiety during chemotherapy and in
between visits
we do recognize that one of the
challenges of virtual reality is that
data generation is enormous and enormous
amounts of data billions of data points
are generated with each study so
selecting which are most relevant to be
acquired and organized and preserved is
a very critical research test that we've
taken on here
as we look to the Future though we look
to learn from other parts of research
other scientific groups and now I want
to take my last few minutes to talk to
you about how the National Library of
Medicine is actually helping us with
that the National Library of Medicine in
the United States is almost 200 years
old it is the primary Nexus for
literature and genomic data sharing for
the world mostly electronic now and it
has particular features to help to
support advancing virtual reality and
nursing research and practice in our
history at the National Library of
Medicine we have reached we have begun
from being a bookshelf in a field or in
hospitals tent in 1836 to 2036
envisioning a future of the 21st century
Library where data science accelerates
Discovery reaches scientists and Society
with trustable information in the period
of time between 1968 and 2000 the
National Library of Medicine benefited
from the enormous digitization nation of
the world but importantly the Visionary
leaders we had saw that this should not
only be for for scientists but for Lay
people around the world so we have a
vast network of health information that
provides people in everyday living in
almost uh 35 different languages help
with their lives we conduct research and
we also support the analysis of data
our strategic plan right now has three
goals accelerating discovering advancing
Health through data-driven research
reaching more people in more ways to
enhance dissemination and engagement and
building a Workforce for data-driven
research and health my personal research
focuses and is supported by that middle
pillar reaching more people in new ways
I Envision a time where reading becomes
only a part of the way we understand
knowledge and visualization whether it's
visualization of an experiment or
visualization of a physiologic process
helps people understand and can better
experience the knowledge they need for
taking care of others or taking care of
themselves the National Library of
Medicine is probably best known through
its products and services PubMed and
PubMed Central are two literature
databases are particularly widely used
around the world PubMed has over 32
million citations in it right now it's a
huge amount of data we'll talk about how
we're making that more accessible in
just a minute our biological and and
genomic databases are also listed here
the sequence read archive or genbank
clinicaltrials.gov is an enumeration of
over a 300 000 clinical trials many of
them actively recruiting and over 50 000
of them have results reporting so the
National Library of Medicine provides a
platform for dissemination of
information about nursing research and
also helps nurse researchers plan new
studies by being able to evaluate our
clinical trials Repository
at the nlm we have high value genomic
databases we also focus on using common
terminologies health terminologies and
standards an important and relevant to
nursing of course would be the
terminologies such as the nursing
intervention classification or nursing
diagnosis we also have been using
machine learning to Cluster clinically
meaningful indicators so that when an
institution a hospital wants to
determine is a patient really getting
improving in their diabetes self-care we
can bring several different variables
together to provide a composite score
we serve millions of people 24 hours a
day seven days a week we have over 15
million accesses a day to our resources
many of them buy computers but many by
people we also support and during this
time of covet sequence-based Public
Health uh strategies to make sure that
we can understand the biological basis
of illness we use standards to help make
data fair and promote access to
controlled data sets that is making sure
that people are properly authorized to
see data sets and we conduct research to
Define and develop new ways
here's an example of some of our
research I mentioned we have 35 million
citations in PubMed Central and it's
really hard when you do a PubMed search
to actually get the ones that you find
most relevant but using machine learning
and artificial intelligence we take the
search strategy that resulted in a
series of hits articles that you might
find useful but then we apply a special
learning to rank algorithm that gives
the best match to your query at the top
of your search list we've learned that
providing people with 10 or 20 pages of
citations in a search is actually not
helpful most people don't go past the
first or second page so we want to use
artificial intelligence to bring these
forward we're now using some of the same
machine learning that decodes images to
make sure that we're bringing the proper
articles with proper figures in them to
the attention of our readers
we also work in the community in the
clinical practice area Nigam challenge
work has applied artificial intelligence
to provide in the moment consultations
to help understand what how does my
patient look like other patients we've
taken care of so bringing together the
wisdom of librarians and clinicians data
scientists to understand what treatment
next steps should be taken for this
individual is one of the ways that the
National Library of Medicine brings
literature and clinical records together
for care we also leverage public
projects public resources such as Google
Street View to better understand the
social determinants of Health by using
the zip code of the individual award
April to help clinicians see the
community they the amount of walkability
the access to grocery stores that might
be important to helping a person achieve
their care goals
because of the changing nature of
research across the the NIH campus and
the world we know we understand that
that improved design increasing the
acceleration of informatics applications
to clinical research particularly
language and terminologies is really
very very important for the next few
years but fundamentally the bottom
bullet we must engage communities in
design and implementation of research
because community-based growth is where
nursing needs to be going we see a
change in scientific Communications
micro Publications or early Publications
presentation of data as a publication in
itself but importantly in Innovative
presentations of smart research results
is what we'll see happening in the
future
I go up close by commenting on Health
Data standards these are primarily
English language standards but they
ensure that data generated in one
clinical setting or in one study can be
compared to or comparable to others on
the screen in front of you you see a
number of key terminologies the mesh
terminology which is a medical subject
heading snomed is clinical terminologies
snowmen is used globally RX Norm is a
medication or pharmaceutical terminology
is a laboratory study vsac is an
accumulation or a linking together of
terminologies that make it more
appropriate to describe a patient
holistically and fire is a message
standard sort of like the address facing
on an envelope where you get familiar
with which piece of information goes in
which order supporting terminologies and
disseminating them is a critical role of
the NIH the growth we need from the
National Library of Medicine is to
develop standards and terminologies to
describe visual cues and visual
experiences and I believe in the next
few years we're going going to be seeing
greater characterization of things such
as walking or motion or the emotive
context between a patient and a family
member
the National Library of Medicine invites
you to join us for the future to think
where visualization can take us for
Global health information where can we
go what can we do and how do we do this
together with you I close by commit
reminding you that our fundamental
commitment is to provide trusted
information algorithms and visualization
to the world and I encourage you to
contact me if I can be of assistance I
write post a blog every Wednesday
morning sometimes it describes activity
specific to nursing sometimes we bring
in colleagues from across campus to tell
us what's going on in their activities
my email address is on and my I'm active
on Twitter so please reach out